Aujourd'hui, on va parler d'une substance terrible.
Son inhalation peut causer la mort par asphyxie.
C'est le plus important des gaz à effet de serre, et le principal composant des pluies acides.
C'est un puissant solvant, largement utilisé par les industries chimiques.
D'ailleurs, on en a retrouvé plein à Fukushima.
On le trouve, en très forte concentration, dans les océans, les fleuves, les rivières…
La plupart des jeunes délinquants en consomment, et même après un rinçage prolongé, il en reste toujours des traces.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de l'eau.
Et vous allez voir que c'est une substance assez étonnante, qui possède des propriétés plutôt bizarres, mais qui la rendent justement idéale pour accueillir la vie.
*Musique de générique*
Bon, commençons par les basiques. L'eau est une molécule, H2O, composée de deux atomes d'hydrogène et d'un atome d’oxygène, ok.
L'une des propriétés les plus bizarres de l'eau, c'est quelque chose qu'on a tous déjà expérimenté, c'est le fait que quand l'eau liquide devint de la glace, son volume augmente.
Et du coup, il se passe... ça.
Bon, donc petit rappel, il existe, principalement, trois états de la matière, solide, liquide et gazeuse. Ce qu'on appelle communément "l'eau", c'est l'état liquide de H2O.
Si on va au dessus de cent degrés, l'eau devient un gaz, c'est la "vapeur d'eau"
En en dessous de *zéro* degré, l'eau liquide se solidifie et devient, de la "glace".
Et il se trouve que la densité de la glace est plus faible que celle de l'eau liquide.
La densité de l'eau liquide, c'est 1.0 et celle de la glace, à peu près, 0.9.
Donc, à masse égale, la glace occupe environ 10% de volume en plus.
Et ça, c'est un truc tout à fait exceptionnel. Pour la plupart des corps, en fait, c'est l'inverse. Le solide est plus dense que le liquide.
Par exemple, l’éthanol, ce qu'on appelle "l'alcool", sa densité c'est 0.8 à l'état liquide et c'est 1 quand il est solide.
L'aluminium, 2.4 liquide et 2.7 solide
Le fer, *7.1* et *7.9*.
Oui, le fer c'est assez dense. Un bout de fer de la taille d'une brique de lait, c'est, à peu près, 8 kilogrammes.
Donc, normalement, les solides sont plus denses que les liquides et il y a une bonne raison pour ça, ça a à voir avec l'organisation des états de la matière.
Dans un gaz, les molécules sont assez éloignées les unes des autres. Elles ne se touchent pas, sauf quand il y a des chocs entre elles.
A côté de ça, un liquide, c'est un état où les molécules sont liées les unes aux autres, mais d'une manière qui est mouvante, qui est désordonnée.
Et un solide, c'est un état où les molécules sont, aussi, liées les unes aux autres, mais de manière bien structurée, dans une organisation qu'on appelle, un "cristal".
Et généralement, l'organisation bien ordonnée d'un solide, sous forme de cristal, elle prend moins de place que l'organisation désordonnée d'un liquide.
Un peu comme quand vous essayez de ranger des cubes dans une boîte. Les ranger en ordre, ça prend moins de place que les ranger en désordre.
Et donc, en général, le solide est plus dense que le liquide correspondant.
Sauf que, c'est pas toujours vrai. L'eau est une exception à cette règle, parce qu'en fait, sa structure cristalline n'est pas si compacte que ça.
Et, il y a quelques autres composés qui montrent le même phénomène, mais il n'y en a pas beaucoup. Il y a, notamment, le bismuth, le gallium, le plutonium et puis, l'acide acétique.
Le fait que la glace soit moins dense que l'eau, ça a une conséquence essentielle.
La glace, elle ne coule pas, elle flotte. Comme les icebergs, ou bien les glaçons dans votre verre.
Et ça, c'est crucial pour le développement de la vie.
Si vous prenez un lac, par exemple quand il gèle à l’extérieur, de la glace peut se former en surface,
mais elle va rester en surface, puisqu'elle flotte.
Et cette glace, elle isole, dans une certaine mesure, le reste de l'eau du lac.
Et va empêcher, généralement qu'elle congèle complètement.
Et c'est ça qui permet de protéger la vie aquatique pendant la saison froide. Si la glace était plus dense que l'eau, elle coulerait au fond et le lac pourrait geler progressivement, avec de la glace qui s'accumule par le bas.
Alors attention, ce raisonnement, il vaut pour l'eau douce, si on considère l'eau de mer, c'est un peu plus compliqué, parce que la présence du sel va modifier, à la fois la densité de l'eau,
mais aussi sa température de congélation.
Mais bon, dans tous les cas, si la glace ne flottait pas,
il est probable que la vie n'aurait pas pu se développer dans l'eau.
Bon, maintenant qu'on a parlé de la glace, on va pouvoir parler de la vapeur...
*Musique de générique*
On l'a dit, dans des conditions normales, l'eau bout à cent degrés, c'est-à-dire qu'elle passe de l'état liquide, à l'état gazeux.
Et c'est ce gaz, que l'on appelle de la vapeur d'eau.
Alors attention, une petite précision, contrairement à une idée répandue, cette espèce de fumée blanche là, ce n'est pas de la vapeur d'eau !
La vapeur, elle est totalement invisible et en fait, ce que vous voyez là, ce sont des petites gouttelettes d'eau, donc de l'eau liquide,
qui proviennent de la vapeur qui vient juste de se condenser au contact de l'air ambiant.
Puisque l'air ambiant est plus froid que la température qui régnait dans la bouilloire.
Bref, l'eau bout à cent degrés et donc, à température ambiante, elle est sous forme liquide.
Et ça, en fait c'est pas normal du tout.
Si on regarde les molécules qui ressemblent à l'eau, en fait on se serait attendu à ce que l'eau soit plutôt gazeuse, à température ambiante.
Pour voir ça, on peut regarder le tableau de Mendeleïev.
L'eau, on l'a dit, c'est de l'oxygène avec deux atomes d'hydrogène.
Et, en fait, autour de l'oxygène, dans le tableau, on trouve d'autres éléments qui forment des molécules avec l'hydrogène.
Par exemple, l'azote forme NH3, qu'on appelle l'ammoniac et qui est un gaz, à température ambiante.
Le carbone, forme CH4, le méthane, un gaz aussi.
Le soufre, forme H2S, le sulfure d'hydrogène, un gaz.
Mais aussi, HF, HCl, H3P, tous des gaz.
Mais non, H2O, c'est un liquide.
Alors, ce que vous savez peut-être, c'est que le tableau de Mendeleïev, c'est aussi intéressant de le lire par colonne, parce qu'en fait, une colonne regroupe des éléments qui ont des propriétés chimiques assez analogues.
Par exemple, si on regarde dans la colonne du carbone, je vous ai dit, le carbone forme CH4.
En dessous de lui, on a le silicium, qui peut former SiH4.
Le germanium, GeH4, l'étain, SnH4, etc...
Et plus on descend dans la colonne, plus on forme des molécules de masse élevée.
Et il y a une chose, assez connue, c'est qu'en général, plus une molécule est lourde, plus sa température d’ébullition, la température à laquelle elle devient un gaz, augmente.
Par exemple, sur ce graphique, vous voyez les composés qui sont formés dans la colonne du carbone, avec leur masse et leur température d'ébullition.
Et on voit que les plus petites ont des températures d'ébullition plus basses.
Alors, faisons la même chose avec la colonne de l'oxygène. Voici les températures d'ébullition de H2Te, H2Se, H2S
et puis, H2O, cent degrés, on l'a dit.
Vous voyez ce truc bizarre ? L'eau, elle bout beaucoup plus haut que ce à quoi on se serait attendu.
Intuitivement, en regardant le reste du graphique on aurait pu imaginer que l'eau allait bouillir vers moins cent degrés, donc qu'à température ambiante elle soit un gaz, et pas un liquide.
Mais non, elle bout beaucoup plus haut, et donc, c'est un liquide.
Et ça, c'est vraiment tant mieux pour nous, parce que le fait que l'eau soit liquide, est quelque chose d'absolument essentiel pour que la vie puisse se développer.
Le vivant, ce sont tout un tas de réactions chimiques, assez complexes, et donc, il y a des molécules qui doivent pouvoir
voyager, se rencontrer, interagir, s’agencer, etc
Et pour ça, le liquide, c'est idéal.
Dans un gaz, les contacts entre les molécules, ils sont trop rares. Il y aurait une réaction chimique tous les trente six du mois.
Et la vie aurait bien du mal à se développer.
Inversement, dans un solide, tout le monde est un peu coincé, donc c'est pas facile, pour les molécules, de bouger, d'avoir une chance de se rencontrer, les unes les autres.
Non, le liquide, c'est vraiment parfait pour des réactions chimiques.
Les molécules, elles sont proches les unes des autres, mais elles peuvent, quand même, bouger librement.
Et donc, si l'eau était un gaz à température ambiante, il n'y aurait, vraisemblablement, pas de vie sur Terre.
Peut-être qu'il aurait fallu aller un petit peu plus loin, pour trouver de l'eau liquide,
mais du coup, il fait plus froid et, énergétiquement, c'est un peu moins favorable pour l'apparition de la vie.
D'ailleurs, si on regarde les autres gaz qui sont autour de H2O,
et qu'on regarde leur température d'ébullition, les deux autres candidats qui sont les plus probables pour, aussi, abriter la vie,
ce sont, le méthane, CH4 et l’ammoniaque, NH3
Bon, pour qu'il soit liquide, il faut quand même aller en dessous de moins cent-soixante et un degrés pour le méthane, et de moins trente trois pour l'ammoniaque.
Et donc, même si on n'en connaît pas, évidemment, à l'heure actuelle, on pourrait imaginer une forme de vie qui soit basée sur ces liquides, plutôt que sur l'eau.
Et d'ailleurs, il y a un endroit où cette forme de vie existe peut-être,
c'est sur Titan.
Titan, c'est un satellite naturel de Saturne, c'est la deuxième plus grosse lune du système solaire, plus grosse que notre lune à nous.
Et c'est la seule qui possède une vraie atmosphère.
Et encore plus fort, à part la Terre, c'est le seul corps du système solaire qui possède du liquide en surface.
Parce que oui, de l'eau, on en trouve à d'autres endroits du système solaire, parfois elle est même liquide,
mais, à part sur Terre, ce liquide, il n'est jamais en surface.
Alors que, sur Titan. Il y a du liquide en surface, ce n'est pas de l'eau, c'est du méthane.
Il y a des mers de méthane, des lacs de méthane, des rivières de méthane.
Et peut-être, à l'intérieur, une forme de vie basée sur le méthane.
Le fait qu'il y ait tout ce liquide à la surface de Titan, on le sait grâce aux images de la mission Cassini Huygens, et en 2005, la sonde Huygens s'est même posée à la surface de Titan.
Allez ! Du coup, je vous quitte sur ces belles images, et je vous laisse imaginer ce qui peut se trouver dans ce liquide...
*Petite musique de fond*
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, comme d'hab', vous pouvez liker, commenter, mais surtout partager la vidéo, pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez retrouver les actus sur facebook, sur twitter et, ceux qui le souhaitent, peuvent me soutenir sur tipeee. Merci, à bientôt.